[Music]  ever since I got together with my new  girlfriend I've been struggling to give  up tinder  I'm not interested in cheating I just  like the validation that comes when  someone matches with me am i doing  something wrong  hmm if you have a new girlfriend if it's  your girlfriend  not just somebody you datin or whatever  you're doing you gotta give up tender  you got to give it up  I'm sorry it's a new girlfriend I mean  you know I'll stay on tinder just in  case you never know you don't have to  fire backup your tinder account you know  if things go south really quick my  advice would be but that's probably not  the way to go I'm not I know what that  means women I'm not interested in she is  that Grindr the grinders more like dirty  you just go for whatever's available  already I cannot even finish this  question you should get off tinder go  straight to grind tender tender tender  tender  what's tinder it's an app yes I don't  I've got a phone book on my phone  [Music]